I'm Neal I'm Garrett I've seen Star Wars
I have not seen Star Wars and I want to
talk about it in front of Neil yeah but
Neil is telling me I can't today we're
gonna said what national Star Wars
spoiler day is when do you think it's
okay to spoil Star two weeks after the
release probably when the movies out of
theaters at least seven days at least a
week one seven days standard calendar
week if you don't want to hear the
spoilers you should see it opening
weekend
I think 2016 is fair game I would say
January first it's open season one year
with full year's and month never get
away from me I don't think it's ever
cool to say the end of a movie thank you
look around you know be aware of your
surroundings just don't be a dick about
it don't be a dick personally I don't
really care about someone's all I want
to know is if the black guy dies or not
I think after a week you can you can
talk about it freely but if someone asks
you to stop talking about it you should
still stop talking about I don't think
you need to spoil it like so many people
have seen it they can just talk about if
people who've seen it like I don't think
you need to tweet like what happens
during it if someone hears people
talking about Star Wars and I haven't
seen it it's like their responsibility
to get out of the conversation should I
feel bad for not having yeah yeah you
should like no but if you're gonna [ __ ]
about spoilers you got to go see it me
I'm trying it's hard to get tickets kind
of feels like you're you're like making
excuses you need only just go see it so
that everyone can talk about it it's not
fair to not do it if you're not gonna
prioritize it what if I told you guys
waiting to see it with my family with my
parents
Star Wars is a unique thing a lot of
people have a very deep family
connection to the movie so even though
it is the biggest release of all time it
is realistic that people are waiting for
their family to see it at Christmas I
think it scales on cultural impact and
the cultural impact is so great if Star
Wars that it pushes everything back but
cultural impact means everyone sees it
the first weekend if you don't you're in
trouble I think that the the Darth Vader
twist up at the end of Empire Strikes
Back
that's something that can never be
replicated again I think maybe six
senses maybe the last one that we as a
culture will ever get to experience
because of the way the internet works
we're just we're not willing to allow
people surprises anymore okay so we've
got a lot of answers we talked to a lot
of people we calculated it a national
Star Wars spoilers day is January 1st 20